we don't talk to your defense too much
in this draft it's an outrageous
question it's time we had quitty pay on
for my alma mater
um and let's stay in the big ten right
here because this guy can hit you
this guy can thump we all saw the tampei
buccaneers yeah we're talking about
mike evans godwin gronk antonio brown
brady i've heard of him
who are some of the stars of that team
that actually brought it home levante
david
devin white guys in the middle of that
thump
and from the penn state university
football program
micah parsons here on the rich eisen
show how are you micah
i'm good sir how are you doing i'm doing
better for talking to you are you going
to bring the
the thunder in this conversation micah
you know
you only know one speed i imagine yeah
sure
okay you could come down and he could
you can you could fill that gap and hit
the conversation
i would think so right yes sir okay okay
very good good talking to you no i'm
just kidding
uh welcome to the show sir so uh what
was your 2020 season like as you you
were one of the uh
handful of big time players who uh opted
out
of the season well it was full of work
and film work
you know we was grinding every day uh
watching college football and watching
nfl so i think this is like
the most i ever watched football during
a football season
what were you watching what what uh what
film were you watching
i was watching my penn state film of
course and then obviously i watched some
of my favorite linebackers play a lot
more this year
you know i got to watch you know devin
white played like as you were saying i
got to watch tremaine edmonds
i got to watch um devin bush before
towards acl
you know so guys like that you know guys
i think i can relate to
so uh are you as good as those guys
you know i'm not going to sit here and
say that but you know i think i got the
potential be as good or better
and so um you know why why do you feel
that way i'd love to hear this sort of
stuff go for it
you know i just think i'm gonna bring
that competitive edge you know i got a
lot of dog to me
you know um i'm gonna go get it
regardless you know and i think i can
achieve anything i'm gonna put it with
the work in
and you know i thought all the 10 moves
are even more tangibles than they got so
for me to sit here and say that i don't
got it which is false i know i got it i
just gotta
do it myself and go compete at the next
level have you
uh have you always played defense or are
you one of uh um
the many top linebackers who have i
guess started out as a running back on
the other side of the whole
trying to fill out yes i started as a
running back i did everything
man my senior year i was the kicker the
punter
the uh running back the linebacker the
defensive end
i did everything so who was your guy
growing up who was your favorite nfl
player growing up
micah parsons uh my favorite nfl player
going up
man it might have had to be uh
when i was younger i was a big lt guy
and then um
then i'm gonna say it it went it went
into like you know
randy moss you know so i kind of
actually i'm gonna
i'm just staying with randy because i
always watch him he's like i don't need
to warm up
so i always had that mentality
i'm i'm coming game ready okay i like
that and i asked this question
at the risk of being older than the
actual 51 years i am on this planet when
you say
lt you mean ladainian tomlinson and not
lawrence taylor right micah yes sir
oh boy you know there was an lt before
uh uh tomlinson and he he he plays this
similar level of football
i mean in terms of three levels of
defenses that you do
right micah of course okay i just wanted
to make actually
i had to ask i just really had to ask
and i love the way you're like of course
i love it so who is your favorite
defensive player
growing up my favorite defensive player
um i love ray ray was a monster
and then you know obviously before
retired i love luke
luke was just different no doubt about
that have you ever had a conversation
with ray lewis
micah parsons no never would you like to
have a conversation
with ray lewis of course okay there's
another of course
i will do this i will hook you guys up
how does that sound
sounds terrific it would be my pleasure
to do that because he knows that
position and he knows about what beats
inside and he knows about
how that position and what beats inside
is the heartbeat potentially for an
entire team
an organization like you can you can
lead from that spot for not just the men
and
around you in the huddle but for every
single human being that puts
puts on a uniform that day or comes to
work in that building that's a fact
he was one of the greatest leaders and
greatest players to ever do it
okay micah parsons here on the rich
eisen show who have you spoken to
sir who have you uh had zoom
conversations with
um i had zooms with um every team
all 32 yes sir okay
um and who did you feel like you got
you know a vibe that they're interested
in you
and can take i would say um i had really
good calls with
the dolphins the really good cause with
the raiders
the lions the giants um
denver um dallas
so i think those teams like um i had
like really good
like uh really good game calls for it
okay
i've got um i've got uh the head coach
of the lions coming on
in 13 minutes and dan campbell was he on
that zoom with you
uh yeah he was on one of the zooms okay
what'd you like about what you would you
what'd you like about that conversation
we had a good feeling
um you know i think we all got the same
mission same game plan
same type of mentality um same
uh work ethic what we want out of a
coach and player
and did you talk to the eagles just a
young man
you did from harrisburg pa and penn
state university
to you you could kind of like make your
way east to play your professional
football
you know yeah i could what do you think
about that idea
i think uh it's a great idea a great
opportunity you know obviously be able
to stay close to home
i always loved that and uh you know a
chance to keep networking and building
on my east coast
okay and uh were you one of the
prospects
that nick ciriani and the eagles played
rock paper scissors with
over the zoom no i wasn't we're not
what would you i think he's pretty lucky
because i would have beat him okay
uh micah let's do this right now here on
the rich eisen show
um i'm assuming you're not watching on
peacock right now correct you don't see
me we're just having this conversation
right all right i am holding out right
now either a rock paper or scissor
so this is my way of doing it on the
count of three
you say yours okay ready
one two three paper all right we're even
oh ty here we go
next up micah i'm going to hold out once
again right here on the show
let's do it one two three go paper
i have it again here we go
you got me okay yes sir
see you're a thinker in the middle of
that defense you've got the neck up
right there i could see that
yeah you know you got to think a little
bit ahead you know i do
because i thought you were going to rock
right out of the gate i did that with
penae sewell and he went rock like right
out of the gate i'm like come on now
i thought about that but i thought you
would go papers so i was like let me
just step back for a second why do i
come across as a paper
[Laughter]
i think when you say rock paper scissors
shoot get like burned in your brain like
oh you gotta think rock that's what i
would think
you know like somebody from the middle
of the defend you're the rock of the
defense you can be rolled downhill and
hit somebody that's what i thought
that's why i went paper
that's because i wanted to win i see
your competitive spirit i think you all
just out thought me they're very well
done micah parsons
you're you're an nfl prospect i'll tell
you that you're honored
i like it fantastic um so you're going
to the draft correct are you going to be
in ohio
for the draft yes sir who's coming with
you tell me about your family
my mom my brother my uh sister
my son um how old is your son
my son is about to turn three may first
oh my gosh
what's his name malcolm malcolm
i mean three is just right on the edge
there might have a nice little memory of
this for quite some time to come
what's that going to mean for you to be
surrounded by that
group of people to have the dream of
being drafted into the nfl realized
micah you know
for me it's gonna mean everything like
it's gonna mean so much to me because
like i feel like as a player
and as a person you know growing up
where i grew up
i just went through so much adversity so
much like
trials and tribulations so many like
do's and don'ts and this is gonna be
like my first time
like i've ever felt like all the hard
work i put in and
you know just to get here has finally
paid off and you know i can finally take
care of my parents like
um and then just be able to change the
whole generation of my family
you know and really just bring up i'm
like i would say and just
upload to my community just to show
people like you know we can do
things bigger than ourselves and you
know give back
so for me it's like so much bigger than
me i like
that's why i always kind of preach
harrisburg pa just so like people know
where i come from
and you know know that like when you
come from harrisburg you come from a
small
city you know we kind of all rallied
together
because you know not a lot of people
make it out of here and i feel like i
was kind of an outlier
so you know making out where i came from
and being a physician was like amazing
can you walk me through some of the
trials and tribulations you're referring
to
that uh you're willing to share with us
right now yeah man like
you know i feel like growing up i dealt
with like a lot of failure and you know
struggling for like school you know
obviously coming from
a different type of school and then
transferring to central golfing
and you know i was like you should kind
of like make excuses and like
um you know until like one time i just
like you know what like
i got to figure it out like i can't keep
going this path because like i always
say like
i wanted to be a football player like
that's something i always known and
wanted to do but i needed something else
you know to make me like you know i
needed school
and i realized that and you know i went
from like a struggling person
to like i was like you know what i'm
gonna put the work in and i'm gonna find
a way
and i'm gonna you know graduate i'm
gonna you know get my gpa
up and i'm gonna find a way to
make this happen for myself and my
family so
and you know i wanted to prove everyone
wrong um nobody believed that i could do
it so
you know for me to do that it was like
crazy and i think that's why like when i
got went to college like
i made this mindset that i was going to
graduate and i was going to do all these
big things because
i felt like i had to i had this chip on
my shoulder
that i wanted to be like more than just
an athlete
and i did that your mom must be
out of her mind right now six days to
get yeah she
like when i graduated heights like
college like tears came to her eyes and
we it sucked because
it was a resume right and i wasn't with
her but like you know to see her smile
and
saw that you know i got my degree for
her she was like the happiest person in
the world and like that's like my best
friend so
when i come to her i'll do anything to
make her happy what's her name
cherise carson okay so charisse is going
to have her moment because it's her
moment as much as it is yours
on thursday night i cannot wait to see
that i'll be on the draft set and i will
be
i will be enjoying that for you and your
family
micah congratulations in advance thank
you sir i really appreciate it
yeah you got it are are are you uh
opening up all those checks that's uh
gonna start coming in right now is that
what you've been doing this during this
entire conversation it sounds like
you're ripping open envelopes of all
these uh
all of these companies that want to hire
you to be their
face front individual as a spokesman as
somebody who's going to be coming
downhill for them too is that what
you're doing
i wish i wish i had some checks in my
hands well it's coming
i'll tell you that it's on the way uh i
look forward to seeing you and your
family
on thursday night micah and uh and i
look forward to
chatting with you down the line um if
this is your cell phone
i wrote it down um because i could see
the caller id i'm gonna hook you up with
ray lewis
as a thank you for being on this show
hey i appreciate it and you know i
really appreciate you for making that
connection having me on your show
and you know when you see me make sure
you say stop by and say hello
i will do that you got it you take care
of yourself micah parsons we'll see in
ohio
yes sir you got it that is micah parsons
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here